[Music]
i think it's important to establish some
of these terms
agi stands for artificial general
intelligence
and agi refers to computers that are
human-like
in their strategic
and capability
today's computers and the today's
algorithms are extraordinarily good at
generating content misinformation
guidance helping you with science and so
forth but they're not self-determinative
they don't actually have the notion of
who am i and what do i do next
if you ask gpt 3 who it is
gpt 3 will say i'm a computer
but it won't give you
a philosophical basis
for its existence its purpose and how
it's determining where it goes
that is the distinction between ai and
agi in my view
now within the community the agi
optimists think that within 10 years we
will have such computers
the pessimists think that it will be far
longer if ever
so let's say 15 years from now
it may be possible to have computers
that have a sense of self-determination
that they know roughly what they're
trying to achieve
against a broader
objective many people think that this
will become an enormous competition
between humans
because remember that those computers
will be faster learners than humans
they'll have access to more data than
humans other people believe that they'll
be fundamentally flawed
because they won't have the nuance they
won't have the background they won't
have the cultural background of the
countries that we all grow up in and the
cultures we grow in we don't really know
my own view
is that this will occur
but that the amount of computation
required to do this will be so great
that there will only be a few of them
and furthermore they'll become so
important that they'll be like nuclear
weapons
and let me tell you why
let's imagine you have a truly evil
person who encounters this agi what's
the first question they'll ask them tell
me how to kill a million people
obviously a terrible
terrible thing to ask and answer
and the agi because it doesn't have
morals
could actually answer
it could actually say well do this this
this and this and furthermore it could
articulate something that's not
generally known because it knows
everything
so i think a fair reading of these agis
is that they're going in the in the most
extreme form they're going to be so
powerful that they're going to have to
be protected
we don't want them broadly used they're
going to have to be used in specialized
scenarios
now such an intelligence will be
enormously valuable
for drug discovery material science uh
climate change
uh making the world more efficient
making uh making people more educated
and imagine with an agi you could say
tell me how to teach a million children
english better and he could figure that
out
because he could in its own thinking to
agree it's thinking it could look at all
the patterns figure out how to do it and
you could actually ask it to write the
program
the beginning of this is today there are
companies that are offering tools which
will help you write code
they don't know what code you're trying
to write but once you start it can fill
in a bunch of it for you
that's the beginning of this phenomena
in the extreme case
there are scientists and basically
science fiction around the future that
could use something called
the singularity
which is the point where the computer
evolution is so much faster than humans
now that's speculation
when you talk to people in my world
most people think the singularity will
occur 20 years from whenever you ask
them that question
so that would say
2041.
you